join me as I unveil my secret recipe for
crafting alluring vintage microfilm
Aesthetics in After Effects
[Music]
hi my name is Cameron and I'm the
creator of motion science before we get
started today I want to invite you to
join my complimentary workshop at
motionscience.tv Workshop where I unveil
my personal techniques and hidden gems
that I use in my daily workflows this is
a free workshop and takes about 30
minutes don't miss out on the chance to
level up your skills and make sure to
visit
motionscience.tv Workshop after watching
this video you won't regret it when I
start personal projects I start by
deciding what to create and then finding
inspiration and setting the intention to
make something memorable I usually
create short motion pieces to focus on
finishing details and also to put them
on my demo reel even if the personal
piece doesn't end up on my reel creating
it helps me to grow as a motion designer
the first step in my process is finding
visually striking footage one of my
go-to resources for this is art grid
where I spend around 30 minutes browsing
through their collection of abstract and
macro shots slow motion and time lapse
effects and footage captured through
unique perspectives such as microscopes
or shallow depth of field I look for
footage that has an interesting visual
appeal and can add a dynamic and surreal
element to the project I like to
download a curated selection of around
12 to 14 shots as having too many
options can lead to decision paralysis
once I have the footage I move on to
finding the perfect music to match the
visual elements my current favorite
source for music is epidemic sound again
I spend around 30 minutes browsing
through their collection setting time
limits to avoid getting overwhelmed with
too many options I look for an audio
track that inspires visuals in my mind
and if needed I'll download a few tracks
test them out in different edits and
choose the one that best complements the
footage with the footage and audio
selected it's time to dive into the
assemble edit and a symbol edit involves
arranging and combining individual video
footage and audio to create a cohesive
Montage it's the foundation for the
entire video editing process and sets
the tone for the final product while
longer or more complex projects may
require editing in Premiere Pro followed
by refinement and after effects for the
shorter project at only 7 seconds and
with a limited number of Clips I choose
to edit directly in After Effects for
efficiency and simplicity with an edit
that I am pleased with but not striving
for Perfection as nothing is ever truly
perfect I seek to add a textural layer
like a matte to elevate the visual
appeal of the footage for this project I
use a clip from art grid and I layer the
footage on top of itself utilizing
transfer modes to give the footage an
intriguing speckled glass effect
next I'm meticulously scale and I
position each clip within the framing
texture to maximize visual interest
treating each shot as a separate
composition and aiming for visual appeal
with the composition looking polished I
incorporate a single line of typography
to transform the edit into a title
sequence I strategically place the type
in the longer shot at the end to provide
the viewer with ample time to fully take
in the text I use the rule of thirds to
position the type within the composition
and apply a simple built-in After
Effects preset to animate the type on
screen I customized the preset to my
liking as I believe that small tweaks
can yield much more compelling results
than using a preset Straight Out of the
Box additionally I adjust the keyframes
for the animation so that the type is
already partially revealed when
transitioning to the shot as a pro tip
animation doesn't always have to start
at zero and end at a hundred percent it
can begin further into the process for
things like scaling positioning and
transitions with a composition coming
together I proceed to add a few
transitions to enhance the flow of the
edit I use one transition to seamlessly
connect two video clips and another
transition at the end of the piece to
wrap it up these transitions while
simple help to make the overall edit
even more Dynamic and engaging
with the foundation of my motion design
project in place I move on to the
experimental phase where I Infuse my
personal style and Aesthetics to achieve
this I leverage a variety of effects
starting with built-in options such as
curves Hue and saturation and levels to
establish a cohesive look between shots
and to build the desired color palette
while it doesn't have to be a perfect
color match it needs to be cohesive to
achieve the noisy retro film look I am
going for I also use a few third-party
effects from zybacks and Sapphire I
don't always rely on third party effects
but when I'm trying to achieve a
specific look that a plug-in is
specifically built to create I use that
plugin to save time I also only own
specific third-party effects that align
with my style and workflow I don't
believe in owning every single Plugin or
script available to affect the overall
look of all layers I apply effects to
the adjustment layers at the top of the
layer stack the order of the adjustment
layers plays an important role in the
overall look and feel of the project so
I experiment with different orderings to
achieve the desired outcome
finally as a pro tip I recommend making
any final adjustments to the piece after
taking a break from staring at it for
too long taking a break and coming back
to it will give you a refreshed
perspective if the project is working or
not with the final touches in place I am
satisfied with the outcome of the
project now while it may not be perfect
as nothing ever truly is it meets my
standards and I am confident in sharing
it on social media and possibly even
including it in my reel and there you
have it my process for creating a retro
abstract film inspired motion design
piece I hope this was both informative
and entertaining for you if you enjoy
the video please hit that like button
and consider subscribing to my YouTube
channel for more content just like this
your support means the world to me and
it helps me continue creating content I
would love to hear your thoughts on this
video so please leave a comment or
question below
thank you for watching and I look
forward to connecting with you in my
next video
[Music]